You never can tell.
No, no,
you never can tell.
(Applause and cheers)
Thank you.
I recently had the tremendous opportunity of searching for gold
in the vast mine of songs released by Chess Records,
a Chicago-based label that was really very active in the '50s and '60s in the US
and that music spread all over the world.
And the songs that I'm singing tonight
are from an album that I just put out called, "Playing Chess,"
that pays homage to those songs.
And these guys were really the innovators of rock 'n' roll and soul and R&B
as we now know it.
(Applause)
(Music)
(Singing) Over the mountain,
across the sea,
there's a girl waiting,
she's waiting for ...
me.
(Music)
Over the river,
beyond every cloud,
she's passed the wind blowin' loud.
Over the mountain,
a girl waits for me.
(Music)
Tell the sands,
every blade of grass,
please tell the wind to let my love pass.
Over the mountain,
a girl waits for me.
Tell the moon up --
up in the sky.
Tell all the birds that fly on by
that over and over the mountain ...
my love waits for me.
Oh,
into each dark, starry night,
oh, what a mystery
that's sealed so tight.
Over the mountain,
a girl waits for me.
Tell the moon up --
up in the sky.
Tell the birds that fly by
that over and over the mountain
my love waits for me.
Into each dark and starry night,
oh, what a mystery
that's sealed so tight.
Over the mountains,
a girl waits for me.
She waits for me.
Oh, she waits for me.
I know, I know, I know, I know, I know.
Oh,
I know, I know, I know, I know, I know,
oh oh, oh oh.
(Applause and cheers)